okay being 11 30 i will call uh the work
session on sb 366 to order
and i will recess until the
non-germain amendment hearing is
complete we will reconvene
the work session on senate bill 366
requiring an audit of ballots cast
does anyone have on the committee now
this this bill has been passed by the
house
our task really is to focus on this
and finance
and there is an estimate of expenditures
in here
between fifty and one hundred thousand
dollars
time and
to actually run these ballots through
it's a sampling process as i read the
bill
uh does anybody have any issues with
this
no and if there's no one to testify i
no
i was just trying to figure out
so i'm still trying to figure out where
we are and i thought you said we just
finished the hearing no i reconvened the
hearing because it started at 11 30.
right i came in and recessed it thank
you now i understand so we're basically
effectively opening the hearing on 366
is that what we're doing right now yes
okay
and so just to follow so apparently
there's nobody to testify so you were
going to make a motion on it is that it
just trying to get caught up i'm a
little slow right that's all right
sometimes
thank you
okay motion by maureen yes i would make
a motion of ought to pass on senate bill
366.
okay
second
uh
mr chairman i'm still trying to figure
out what this bill does is this only the
audit this is not a bill that creates
the
the temporary ballots correct
this is uh is basically
sampling
the machines and auditing them with
ballots
so my understanding is the secretary of
state can do this without this bill why
we have this bill like he can just do
i guess that's the answer i mean it has
to have an approval of ex for
expenditures and how much are we given
for this
fifty to a hundred
dollars
a hundred dollars
uh hundreds of companies here from the
secretary of state's office
um could i ask that maybe
for their input just on for clarity
prior to going forward with the vote
just for my own edification sure yeah i
no there's no this is a work session
there's no pink cards no
but we are being
uh live streaming
yes um this bill is
we'd have to um purchase a high speed
scanner um
we expect it's actually going to be the
higher end of the 50 to 100 000 um the
fiscal note this is a bill that's been
here
many times in the past it's going to
require that the secretary of state's
office do
a recount using a high-speed scanner of
two towns or two
two voting locations um
at the primary and four at the general
election and that they have to be done
by noon on friday
which obviously it's a busy week as you
can imagine for the secretary of state's
office uh i think the point of this bill
is trying to give people
confidence
in the machines originally the bill was
to do just a machine not the whole
voting location
and
i sort of explained to them that we're
not used to keeping our
our votes separate by machine so the
chances of there being a you know 100
difference which would do the opposite
of
giving voters confidence in the election
so they did take that out and said it
would be
all of the machines
but it's supposed to be just the um
machine counted
numbers
so i there's still concerns that
towns may put some of their hand counted
ballots in with the machine counted
ballots and and that could cause a uh
a difference but
and
you know i i'm not
looking at it as if we're trying to give
people confidence
really why does it need to be done by
noon on
on friday
um but that's what the bill calls for
that have to be done by
noon on friday
and for the cost i said we have to
either we've looked at if you rent a
high-speed scanner the expenses of
of having it programmed
and
you're not going to be choosing which
towns they're going to be programmed for
until uh just before the election and
the town will not know that they were
chosen
until i think it's um it originally
wasn't built i don't think that changed
until like noon on the the day of voting
so they need to get their ballots to the
secretary of state's office we need to
do the recounts
um the high speed scanner recounts and
have it done by
noon on
friday
yeah we have nothing else to do that
week
so given that
in
let's say weighing the benefit
i'm not sure of that of this compared to
the practicality of it
um
is it practical to do this i mean that
just i'm asking for opinion i know
that's what it's um well that's that's
basically your job to decide if it's
worth it but
whatever the house
whatever the house in the senate passes
and the governor signs the secretary of
state's office
will make happen it doesn't mean that it
might
it'll add a lot to obviously a week
that's um that's that's pretty busy um
for us but
i i guess you have to weigh
is the 100 are we going to be giving
voters
that much more confidence
in the election by doing this um
just to let you know
another bill that has gone through both
the house and the senate
is going to double the number of hand
recounts that are done and i fully
expect that the governor is going to
sign it
every recount that we do
we are going to
also have to do a recount of
one of the races between executive
council and president
so we are we are doubling the number of
of recounts that we will be doing
um which
we weren't doing that the last time that
this bill i mean this this this bill has
been before this committee um
at least a couple other times that i
remember
remember here so we will be doing 100
more recounts
um i expect for both the primary and the
general than we have done in in past
elections so the the decision for you to
make is is the hundred thousand
are we going to be giving you know 100
000 dollars of more voter confidence
in the election by doing these high
high-speed recounts
the week of
so i
just make sure i understand this
correctly the um
genesis bill says to do another machine
count for something that's already been
machine counted to assure that the first
machine count um is accurate is that yes
okay so
and the cost is up to a hundred thousand
plus
uh additional overtime or whatever
happens within the secretary of state's
office i just
um
i just don't see the
benefit that's all thank you mr chair as
as as you're asking the question and a
benefit came to mind
thinking i was thinking that what
lift up the hood on this what does it do
it could be it is a way to discourage
nefarious actions
with voting machines
the fact that some of them are going to
be audited on a random basis
is a deterrent for somebody to mess with
a machine i mean that
under the hood
so it may be a defensive
action as much as it is a confirmation
yeah and and no town knows that they're
going to
have a recount anyway i mean they're as
you all know they're
most of the recounts are related to um
state rep races we do have them
sometimes on senate but we tend to have
more on state rep so no
no town
um
knows that whether or not they're going
to have
have a recount and like this here it'll
it'll be two towns
two towns added to that potential
at the primary and floor at the uh at
go ahead representative
oh thank you mr chairman and thank you
for testifying i agree that audits
recounts aren't going away anytime soon
the purchase of this scanner will can be
used
just for this just for this
all um in in uh
in statute
all recounts
have to be done by hand
this is a
a special exemption
just for these that are done um
the two in the primary and four at the
general done
by noon on friday
follow up
okay but audits can this machinery be
used for future audits
we don't normally the only time that
there is a audit is if there is a
special legislation
by the house and senate and signed by
the governor to do an audit
our
laws
allow anyone to ask for a recount and if
you're
the amount that you lost by was a
certain percentage there's no cost if
it's above that there's additional cost
and you know to the point where if it's
beyond a certain percentage you have to
pay for the entire thing
once that recount is done there is no
provision in our rsas
to do a second recount
or on audit the only time
that that would happen is that there is
special legislation such that as there
was in the wyndham case
just one more follow-up so if that were
to happen if the next legislative
session
somehow mandates an audit could this
equipment be used no because those are
those are hand counts
if you had a
um like like i said the example of the
windham audit that was
we had other people come in they
completely validated the hand count that
the secretary of state's office did
but it's a hand count it's not done by
machines
thank you mr chair
i'm following up on the previous
questions
so this machine
that would be at least
for purchase
purchased
is probably better um i assume then to
avoid issues that other where the
original machines might have had this is
like an air gapped removed from
putting it on i you know the because i
work at the polls
as a as a supervisor of the checklist
basically now at least in my area
it plugs into the phone line
no no it plugs into the wall they're not
they're not connected to the internet
okay none of none of our accu volt
machines
statewide because i thought it
transmitted no it does not transmit no
it's never used to do that so
then i guess the real question i have is
not about how it used to be so
there's a benefit to this
not being attached to anything it's a
standalone
air gap
yes just like our accuvope machines are
standalone
machines
it would be taking
the ballots from the accuvolt machine
whether it's a town that has one machine
or a town that has
or a ward that has two or three machines
we would be taking the ballots from that
one voting location so if it was
if manchester was picked it would only
be one ward in manchester it would not
be any place that's got more than one
voting location
this bill is for one
all the machines in that one voting
location and those machines right now
are not connected
our machines have not been connected to
the internet they are
go ahead and represent
question if this is going to happen are
the candidates
on the ballot notified of it so they can
be part of the public witnessing and if
they choose to
it will be uh
the town will be notified that day and
by noon time on that day
that they have been um they have been
selected and there's nothing in the bill
to notify them
the candidates but i assume that
candidates will probably find out
like it just says we have to notify them
representative patch thank you mr chair
so if i may and i and i understand your
comment that maybe that would be um a
deterrent and a theorist activity but um
those that participate in the theories
activity
do odds
and there's only two
voting machines picked
i mean uh chances of being successful if
you in fact were going to do that are
pretty their odds are with you and also
it's my understanding that it's
as it's structured now it's pretty hard
to
tinker with the voting machines as they
are so i i'm just in all honesty i'm all
for a verified vote i'm all for i'm kind
of tired of hearing how the vote was
rigged um for something that would stem
that activity but i don't see it
can i just back up one comment that um
representative walsh made would it be in
public it would definitely be in public
i mean there is nothing that we do
regarding odd
elections
in this state that are not
that
are not open to the public just like all
of our recounts that we do
whether it's for a state rep or senate
race or executive council whatever those
are all open to the public and this
would also be open to the public like i
said it does need to be done in a very
representative griffin thank you mr
chair
given the controversy we had in the last
election that was surrounded
around the voting machines
i think this is a very important bill
uh just for my uh
you know just to tell the public yes
we're looking at the machines
there's a lot of people who don't have
any faith in the machines
be that be that
unfounded or not
i think that this is a pretty good bill
and will give people a little more faith
in the system
thank you and to follow up on those
comments you're not alone in thinking
that representative griffin because this
bill came out of the election law
committee 20 to zero
that is rare i served on election law
last year maybe some of you did too
previously it's oftentimes quite
partisan and to come out 20 to nothing
is huge also on the consent calendar on
april 15th so that's huge also so
obviously we're not the only ones that
feel that this is important and for this
kind of money i'll be voting for my own
yes
we have a motion on the
motion on the floor by representative
mooney seconded by representative
griffin
okay
oh you do i'm sorry
so i heard on the news this morning that
the secretary of state's office has set
up a commission to look at the security
of voting and i'm wondering if it has
any relationship to what we're
discussing right now it's not security
of elections it's voter confidence
it is it is a uh commission they had a
um
the
press uh meeting was at eleven o'clock
today um i forgot how many members there
are that it may be 15 16 people from
both parties um
and
the the the two um
co-chairs were there that was a press
conference earlier today trying to
address the issue of voter confidence
it's
obviously it's
whether or not
there have been any problems whatsoever
in new hampshire elections i think our
new hampshire elections have been very
safe and fair
there is a
there is a perception and you need to
deal
not only with reality but you have to
deal with people's perceptions and
that's what this commission is going to
be having listening sessions all over
the state they may have some
recommendations for legislation though
it's not specifically set up for that
but we but they may very well come up
with some recommendations for
for future legislation
but my question was
is there a relationship between that
commission and what we're doing here no
no these were both completely
independent of one another
senator divorce yeah just to comment i
know in berlin we secure our machines
you think passing legislation that
require
uh towns or cities to secure the
machines in another place i know in
berlin only the clerk and the assistant
clerk have access to that room there
there are there are uh there is
legislation there are rsas specifically
dealing with that okay thank you
okay without any further comment
thank you very much
now
we have i have a question who's
i need your name for a replacement i'm
sorry that's okay chris with a k
almost all the letters that you could
use
not a problem
okay without further comment if the
clerk would call the role that this is
on uh senate bill
motions 366.
to pass are we gonna have any discussion
on this because i have a point i'd like
no i meant now in this division go ahead
i i think this is a waste of money i
mean we've got one of the most secure
elections in the country we've got as
representative pointing out these
machines are secured
i think this is a solution looking for a
problem and i i agree with i can't
remember who was it talked about the
odds but we're talking about two voting
locations out of probably 200 or more in
this state you're talking about maybe
one percent if if you're going to
mucking around with the election the
odds are you're not going to get caught
by this and i think you know
we're whining about spending money all
over the place i think this is a wasted
hundred thousand dollars and i cannot
support this i again i think this is a
solution looking for a problem that
doesn't exist
we don't have security issues here and i
don't think that the way this is being
put forward there's any way that this is
going to be able to really
bring comfort to those who see problems
that
they think may be there
so that i just wanted to say that before
we vote because again i have a real hard
time supporting this
okay i think that's fine i mean then
vote no because uh
as representative said it came out of
the
committee 20-0
but that's that's the policy committee
we're here whether it's a good use of
money and i'm saying on the money issue
i don't think it's a good use of money
and i'm trying to look at it from a
finance point of view and from the
finance point of view i think this is a
waste of money so somebody may have
thought an election law what the heck
why not you know it's not going to cost
me anything so we'll do something that
might give somebody a sense of security
and then it comes to us to say is this a
good use of money and i'm saying no
we're wasting taxpayers money with this
and i don't think it's a good use to
money okay
thank you for your thought yes
representations thank you sir
um
i'm inclined to agree with her although
i will say i've yet to make up my mind
but
i do know i believe you mentioned mr
chair that this would be a deterrent to
shenanigans
i would hope the existing law
should be
the deterrent to shenanigans
and
i mean i would have more confidence in
this process if it
if the choices were more than two out of
how many voting locations do we have a
thousand something
yeah
i mean
and but the good news is
from all the investigations i know our
secretary of state has taken
uh
on
instances of voter fraud are so
infinitesimal it's not even close to one
percent it's a it's a minuscule
mini fraction if i understood you
correctly and the bigger issue issues
are things like and we've eliminated
this like matching
handwriting on one
you know absentee ballot to the original
form all those sorts of things i mean i
think the the systems we have been
putting in place should
do as good of if not better of a job as
it is now
in my opinion and probably the money is
not
needed
sorry mr mr chairman
i know that some states don't use paper
ballots and that's a problem some states
require you can vote through the
internet which
for me is a big big problem
however you know i tend to agree that i
was thinking about
this being a waste of money
two machines you don't know where
they're going to be
can't be a deterrent at all at all at
all as far as i'm concerned you know i
could see when we're going to be dealing
with perhaps a federal election but you
know that
so with the clerk call the roll
okay the motions have to pass on senate
bill 366
chairman yes
why is jim
yes
no
seconded
okay the motion is itl on senate bill
366.
uh okay the um chairman votes
no no okay no
no uh the clerk votes yes
representative moody no
representative schultz yes
representative hatch representative
walsh yes
uh if the motion is four to three uh the
itl passes okay the motion will go to
full finance tomorrow as ito
and we will vote at the executive
yeah and i put them together they were
supposed to have an hour but somehow the
schedule got messed up so we're going to
do those two bills
being one o'clock i'll call the work
session on senate bill
267 order
and i believe we have an amendment
and commission would you like to speak
to the points of the amendment
[Laughter]
okay this is on amendment
and you've got to turn your mic on
because we're streaming live all right
before the record i am sean jasper
commissioner of the department of
agriculture
and um
the the original bill was
uh senator guida's bill we did work
closely with him
um
on that bill but we're not
in charge of the the final
um
language as this
went through the house
um chairman
pearl actually uh
asked one question which we hadn't
really looked at that's in
section e it's relative to
herbicides in bulk quantities and
distribute that's not really
practical and would not it would require
different licensing for us we don't have
facilities to store it
so um worked on language
that in e and i'm sorry for going
backwards i got ahead of myself but
to subsidize the purchase of herbicides
by municipalities when the funding is
available and have them apply back to us
for reimbursement obviously there's
limited monies here we don't believe
there are a lot of municipalities that
actually
do this themselves so most of the money
that is in the bill would be something
that the department itself would be
purchasing
um and doing the spraying we do have
people that are
licensed to do that we work with
municipalities very careful closely as
well as with the d.o.t
so this this part of it was strictly
something that senator guydo wanted to
put in there to make it a benefit to
municipalities
so now if i move backwards
d is simply
something that in working on this i
caught that we were using two
terminologies the bill itself was
um
i don't have it in front of me so used
one terminology to just
to
describe the program and then section e
used another one so it
it would appear to anybody reading it
that we were really talking about two
different programs when we weren't so
this is just a cons matter of
consistency
thank you all right thank
you does anybody have any discussion
before we pick up the amendment on the
if i maybe it's determined sorry
commissioner um
does the department practice uh integra
integration integrated pest control ipm
management
yes we try we try to so
um
the one person that we have it's not his
primary job but he's sort of moved into
that area and if we do get funding if
this bill passes and then the next year
we get funding he'd be the person
that does that on a full-time basis but
yes we use any any method that's
appropriate we try not to use chemicals
at all if possible so
um our goal is
is to do it as naturally as as possible
but that
but it's not always uh feasible either
particularly when you're dealing with
large quantities particularly of things
like knotweed and
things like that stuff
well thank you for that clarification
because a number of people don't do not
yes represent representative griffin
on senate bill
second
motion made and seconded on the
amendment 1779
you're going to call anybody have any
comments what we call the rule
all right okay this is not the past on
senate bill
the amendment well this is the amendment
for
you want to do it with a show of hands
we could do what the show has no i mean
yes
okay show him okay
all right
want to 267 so i'm just going to go
okay second
motion made and seconded on ah to pass
267 as amended any further comment yes
representative walls
i know i walked in a little bit late
during this but i'm just trying to
understand
why this is outside the budget
your guess is as good as mine
can we ask the commissioner
sure
so you're asking why didn't we just wait
and put it in the budget
coming up for it or why wasn't it
well
so
while this has been a priority of mine
and it was one of the things i i
mentioned when
i was confirmed is that we needed to
deal with invasive species
frankly with the last budget cycle we
were really told to hold off
and so i had to be very creative in
dealing maintaining the department and
there was really no
no ability to expand at that point so
senator guida came aft you know this
year with with this request and we do
feel that it's appropriate to get going
as soon as possible but
um i can't tell you 100 percent that i
would have requested
the funding in a in a previous budget
because i never had that opportunity due
to the constraints that were put on me
at the time but this is
a department uh priority
okay all right that's an answer thank
you
any other quote into the comments
motions made and seconded
uh ought to pass 267
as amended
you want to call the role okay the
yes
mr chairman
i'd like to have a little sympathy for
representative schultz can she vote last
on the democrats instead of first we're
putting her in she did ask for that and
we're putting in her very difficult
position
so i would just ask that we give her the
chance to hear how
others
are voting before we put her on the spot
second
thanks
work session
work session on 267 is
all right now we have
uh senate bill 418 i'll open a work
session on 4 18.
any
i don't know
i don't think this has an amendment no
it doesn't doesn't okay
so it's 418 any comments on 418 yes
certainly
patty lovejoy uh
senior deputy secretary of state i just
wanted to give you some information on
this bill the bill was changed quite a
with its amendment i'm sorry
this bill is requiring is now calling
for
provisional ballots
for those who
register to vote for the first time in
new hampshire
without an id
it is not
the original bill was for all affidavit
voters there are three types of
affidavit voters there's an affidavit
for domicile
there's one age in citizenship
and then there's one for an id
so i mean it's possible that someone
could need all three forms but this bill
now
is related to those that don't have an
id
and were registering to vote for the
first time in new hampshire that day
just to give you some information
the id voters are we call those
challenged voter affidavits that means
you didn't have an id
in the 2020 election there were
733 people
statewide
that voted without an id
we do not keep
information
and our data as to how many of those
were people who just came to vote and
forgot their
their um id versus how many were
registering to vote that day um our gut
belief is that the vast majority of that
733 are people who are already
registered to vote
um and they just forgot their id you
know they you know think well you don't
need to go home you can just you know
sign this challenge voter affidavit
so this bill is related
only to those bills but it still
requires that
for each of those people who are
registering to vote today
and don't have an id with them
they will be given a packet by their by
the moderator and that packet will
include a
overnight envelope to send it to the
secretary of state's office uh the
postage for those is basically thirty
dollars for for each one of them
uh
the
moderator will have to
write on the back of the ballot that
this is
you know um affidavit voter number one
affidavit voter number two etc
uh
theoretically in the bill it says that
those are supposed to be put into the
side pocket in and hand counted at the
end of the day
i think a lot of you have been involved
in elections before if you are the
person that is standing there in front
of the ballot box you know the the
machine
the machine will take a ballot going
this way this way this way you know all
four ways so if a
voter where they've written you know
affidavit voter number five on the back
of it
flips that over and goes to put it in
the machine you are not going to know
that
that was there
there are some things that will need to
be changed eventually if this does go
through
we have
there's an rsa about no extraneous marks
on ballots obviously this is you're
we're telling the moderator to make an
extraneous extraneous vote
um another change that was made in this
um this bill was that it
originally was going to be effective for
the primaries coming up
and the effective date has been put off
to
next year to 2023 so the first time that
this would be in place is for the um
first in the nation primary
we are going to still have a first
nation primary
uh
so there there will be if there's a
court challenge um there there will be
um
time to do that the secretary of state
has taken the position on this bill
that you know that that he was in
support of it but
he would prefer that it would be laid on
the table and brought to the supreme
court to deal with the
constitutional issues
but obviously that's up to the
legislature to decide how you want to um
how you want to handle any bill so
the votes will be counted
if you have one of these affidavit
ballots
your vote is going to be counted that
day
you have seven days to get your envelope
where you are providing your id
information to the secretary of state
if the secretary of state does not
receive that in seven days and each of
the town moderators will have to send to
the secretary of state's office a
listing
of each of the
each of the individuals who voted on
this provisional type of ballot
at after the end of the seventh day
the secretary of state's office will
notify the moderator that you need to
retrieve um ballot number two
six and nine
and
check each uh for each office that they
voted for remove that from your totals
so that's that's the way that this bill
works i just wanted you to
to be sure that you understood what the
bill is um take any questions if you
have any
questions go ahead
yeah thank you mr chairman you mentioned
at the beginning of your testimony a fee
of 30 dollars yes
the secretary of state's office
so that's um as part of the um amended
fiscal note that you have it includes
that
since i had no way of knowing of those
ones that we had last time how many of
them were
you know registering to vote that day
versus how many of them
just forgot their id i assumed that they
were all people that were first-time
voters so the uh
the fiscal note that you have is on
the high side assuming that all 733
of them and obviously we only have to
pay them postage for somebody who
actually
mails it back but the secretary of
state's office will need to provide
these packets
for every every voting location and we
do have 308 i think it is
other questions
yes representative thank you and thank
you for taking the question so of the
733 you referred to yes at the beginning
that was in which election that was in
the 2020 presidential election okay 2020
general yes follow up
so um obviously of those 733
that includes more than just those
registering to vote for the first time
so
if we did an estimate it would be less
than 700 if if i were you my gut feel
it's probably under 200. okay and of
those 733 just give you the full info um
the secretary of state's office needed
to to reach out to all 430
733 people who voted by challenged voter
we sent postcards to all of them 438
returned their cards 215 didn't respond
and there were 45 of the 733 that were
undeliverable
because something is undeliverable does
my i live in stratham my next door
neighbor does not have a
mailbox they have a pl box
and when you register to vote you
register with your address
so that person registering with their
address on the challenge voter affidavit
if you mail the postcard to them the
post office returns it because it's not
deliverable there's no mailbox
there so the um 45 that were returned
undeliverable were not necessarily
you know people who were not valid
voters
representative griffin
is that to be corrected in the future
on the affidavit
um give an address
is there going to be a line for the
mailing address the uh the form of the
so you could change it
yeah
representative schultz of course your
voter registration
form does ask for both yes you have a
separate
but also in between the time that
somebody voted
and when we mailed out the letters we do
not get the letters out you know the
next week maybe in the next month it
takes a while to get you know with
everything that gets done at the end of
the election so somebody could have
moved um from the time that they voted
okay you could have lived in that town
for you know 40 years
you didn't have your id that time so you
had to fill up this thing and you've
moved from the time that we
okay thank you so much have a
contribution for this
please introduce yourself and
make your comments good afternoon my
name is samantha buckley i am here with
sure samantha buckley b u c k l e y
thank you
um
and i am here to discuss some concerns
with sb 418
sb 418 as it's currently written
will disenfranchise active military
voters
currently so for the uniform and
overseas citizens absentee voting act or
you acaba
it requires or guarantees active
military members
45 days as in 45 days prior to a federal
election
their ballots must be mailed out
currently the way that sb14 is written
that can't happen
so certification
is 14 days after the primary that is 14
days after the primary and when you do
the math particularly for 2024
that means that those dates don't really
work
what would happen is essentially
the date of the required mailing would
occur prior to certification
and this actually that means that local
election officials will be forced to
decide do we send a ballot with
uncertified candidate names
or do we send a ballot late and be in
conflict and non-compliant with the
federal law
um 45 days is guaranteed by yuakawa
because federal lawmakers wanted service
members to have every opportunity to
receive their ballot in a timely manner
45 days is to protect against the
possibility of long-care mail carrier
times
specifically when mail is sent
internationally
decreasing this time even by a day
is federally non-compliant and endangers
service members opportunity to receive
their ballot in time
other concerns we do have other concerns
with sb 418
that would include
it is very well it's interesting that
the impact of sb 418
perhaps could be similar to 2017's
failed sb3 bill
which was determined to be
unconstitutional by the new hampshire
supreme court and it cost new hampshire
taxpayers 4.2 million dollars in legal
fees
and 4176
billable hours by the attorney general's
office
418 contains similar a similar impact to
2017's sb3 bill
which established a voter registration
process that occurs after the voter has
cast a ballot and requires the person to
provide documentation of their residency
the new hampshire supreme court did not
consider this new process to theater
voter fraud because the voters still
cast a ballot
other concerns would be that it may also
that sb 14 may endanger new hampshire's
exemption status of the national voter
in vra
it requires an expensive and cumbersome
voter registration requirement process
and that is something that new hampshire
currently is exempt from due to its
long-standing and robust same-day voter
registration process
and an unforeseen consequence of sb4418
if it is pushed to the courts is that
the courts may consider that
new hampshire no longer has that
exemption
there are also state constitutional
concerns because new hampshire does
guarantee a voter confidentiality in
their ballot
sb 418 provides a method and permission
for the state to know how a voter votes
due to the fact that
the state may go in and essentially un
well
basically take away the vote of someone
who's already cast their ballot
um considering all of this we are asking
that sb 418 be voted to be
thank you thank you questions yes
representative griffin
did you have an opportunity to bring
this all before the policy committee
before they
voted uh
yes yes we did so they passed the bill
in spite of that
um
from what i understand originally the
bill was for 10 days to provide for
somebody to provide the documentation
and it was moved to seven however that
doesn't really
deal with the yuakaba concerns
can i ask mr huffman a question what
what what's the difference from what you
oh
all right thank you
iwakava does overseas to overseas
other comments thank you ma'am
okay
okay motion by representative walls for
itl
seconded by representative hatch
given the fact that this is
protecting the rights of active military
and their families i'm against the itl
motion being a veteran and knowing what
it's like being overseas
i would rather see it as an interim
study because there are a lot of points
no i didn't make a motion i was just
making a comment so if you would rather
okay okay
we have a motion for entrance study
same individuals
okay
hey
all right i'm all set
okay
uh the chairman votes no
okay the vice chairman
no
the clerk votes yes
represent mooney no
okay representative hatch yes
representative walsh yes representative
schultz yes
interim study passes four or three mr
chairman okay we'll report to full
finance for tomorrow's executive session
four to three interim study
i'll close the hearing on 418.
the next one is that
next one is uh one three or three
we have two minutes okay cool two
minutes till show time i have time to
since when you're anti-military
now i was talking to
you
yes
yep
um
okay
on the
okay being 1 30 we will open the work
session on senate bill
uh reimbursement of sheriff's
and transportation of
prisoners
do we have any comment
on this bill
please
is that
no
if you would turn your microphone on
introduce yourself please
hey i'm dominic ricciardi carroll county
sheriff
and the president of the new hampshire
sheriff's association could you please
spell your last name it's
r-i-c-h-a-r-d-i
okay you have the floor
okay
dear chairman emmerich and members of
the committee
my name is dominic ricciardi i'm the
high sheriff of carroll county current
president of new hampshire sheriff's
association
the new hampshire sheriff's association
has asked
senator hennessey to bring forward this
bill
i'm here to testify in support of the
bill the custody and control function of
the trance and transporting and handling
of prisoners
is inherently dangerous one
we are asking for our reimbursement
to be equal what the court security
officers are currently
being paid
language in this bill would reimburse
quote at the rates provided in the
collective bargaining agreement
applicable to per diem court security
officers
employed by the judicial branch for the
court security to attend any official
the raid is currently 65 dollars for a
full day
35 dollars for a half a day
that's been in stature for many years
we are finding it harder and harder to
recruit qualified candidates for this
job
we need to be able to pay a fair wage
for doing this work
we are asking for the reimbursement to
be equal to what
court security officers per diem pay is
currently
120 and 18 cents for a full day
and sixty dollars and nine cents for a
half a day
happy to answer any questions that you
may have
i re respectfully ask that you find this
bill out to pass
thank you
you have questions
i have one and i just because this is a
new process to me
so
all this is doing actually is changing
the reimbursement levels it's not really
setting up a new level of
wrong word
it's not
changing a system of any kind it's just
changing
the reimbursement levels correct yes all
right thank you
representative walls
isn't it true that the pay sometimes
varies from county to county some
counties
pay more than others
they pay their officers more than others
currently carroll county
um
pays
a part-time pay
and they're only reimbursed at this
65 level right now
um because
it would be almost impossible to hire
someone at
65 or 65 a day
to do
basically
police work
and i correct that even at these higher
rates of 60 and 120 the counties are
having a hard time recruiting enough
people to fill the open slots
there is currently in any job in uh this
country right now hard time to find uh
someone to hire but it certainly
makes it more palatable
and it
helps the counties
become
not whole but
more complete
in their um
attempting to hire people
mr chairman the reason i'm familiar with
this in the account my work in the
counties and i know that merrimack
county pays more than the rates the
reimburse rates and they still can't
fill the slots i've spoken recently
again with the sheriff and they're
having a terrible time getting enough
people to fill these slots and they're
as i say they're paying more than the
rates that they're being reimbursed for
i just i know i'm testifying but i put
that out there
well it's facts that's all right
any other questions
yes representative pass you got to turn
your you've got to turn your mic on
so i paid the guy that mows my lawn 20
bucks an hour but we have a deputy paid
15 an hour uh it's a total weapon and
keep people safe is that what we're
talking about that's what the state is
reimbursing at yeah the current
reimbursement right yes yeah thank you
any other questions yes representative
griffin oh i will move uh
senate bill 303
uh as octopass
okay we have a motion for out to pass
representative griffin do have a second
representative wall seconds
any other comments
okay
clear call the roll okay the chairman
votes yes the vice chairman yes the
clerk votes yes representative mooney
yes representative hatch yes
representative walls yes representative
schultz yes
okay the motion is seven to nothing and
passes mr chairman
can somebody have another dialogue
anybody have any other dialogue they'd
and we have about 20 minutes to burn
well i will close the hearing on senate
please
okay being two o'clock i'll open the
work session on senate bill 363.
do we have anybody that would like to
good afternoon mr chair members of the
committee i'm carol mcguire merrimack
district 29 which is allenstown epson
pittsfield
and senate bill 363
passed my committee unanimously so i
thought it would come and explain it to
you okay
good
uh the story starts in 2011 when we made
a number of changes to the retirement
system a large number of changes and for
group two we created
pension
data so when you how old you have to be
how long you have to serve how much you
earn for each year
between the vested employees which is
which who had the current
the previous law
the non-vested employees had a
significantly decreased benefit and the
in the interim we stare stepped it up
those people
who had been
who were hired but not yet
10 years of service in 2011 are now
approaching retirement
and they are concerned about this
so
what this bill does is it allows them to
buy
service
to lower the minimum age for retirement
or
uh
and and so forth
so forth so they can retire earlier or
with a better benefit
the important thing that
you need to know is that they are
required to pay the full actuarial cost
of that change
so they can
they can pay now and improve their their
pension for life retire earlier or work
longer their choice
and uh we thought that as long as they
were paying for it it was not
unreasonable to allow them to
buy service up to
what the people who were vested in 2011
had
okay
try to answer questions appreciate your
comment because
here in finance we look at the
fiscal notes and it's got zero zero zero
zero yes the only expense is a is some
programming
in the retirement system to accomplish
this they're going to be paying the full
freight to the change to their benefit
right and so
we thought that was okay
it was worth spending a little money on
just as an aside do some of the people
that we
i'm trying to think of the bill number
now
where we
changed
the eligibility or the
retirement contributions
back to the 2011
was that 1487 i no i don't know that
number
but 1587. but the contribution that each
retiree makes was set i believe in hb2
okay or something like that i just
didn't know if this interface
i'm assuming some of the same people are
affected by both of those oh yes yes
however
that was that was a change to how much
over time they can credit toward their
creation yeah yeah
and there was a cost to it this is a
essentially no cost way for them to
improve their pension up to a certain
level
at their own expense
excuse me
all right
thank you any anybody else like to
thank you mr chairman for the record my
name is james demers and i'm here on
behalf of the new hampshire police
association
and the new hampshire troopers
association in support of this bill
um so you're right rarely do you have a
bill that has a fiscal note that's all
zero so as you heard
the entire cost is paid for by the
individual who might
want to uh take advantage of this
to your point this is the exact same
tier
that
you did house bill 1587 that middle tier
and those are the individuals that you
heard who when they were hired were
hired
with a belief that it was a 20-year
period to retirement and then they had
years added on during that reform
measure anywhere from one to four years
so this bill as you heard
gives them the ability to
buy years above the 20 to get them down
to the 20 that they were hired under so
the expense is fully out of their pocket
and
the one point that i'd like to raise
that
wasn't brought up is that you've heard
through this entire year the challenges
that the state is facing
in law enforcement jobs
and retention has become a gigantic
issue and we're seeing now
a really rare situation where people are
leaving
before they reach their 20 or 25 years
and we think this bill is another tool
that will help retain
individuals if they're thinking about
leaving
and they can buy
the four years to get them back down to
the 20
that may be enough to keep some of the
people on the job so we think it's an
important tool to help
retain troopers and police officers that
might be thinking about leaving early
questions just represented
just for my own interest um and i know
there's a variable because it depends on
their base pay etc but
typically
can you answer how much that would cost
to individual on average or a minimum
maximum yes
yeah so this is not for everybody and i
think there's a very small number of
people that will take advantage of it
because one of the estimates we heard is
that it could be around forty thousand
dollars per year
so if somebody's buying four years it's
a significant sum of money it's a
significant if they buy one
but that gives you an idea that it's
probably going to be limited to a small
thank you
you had a handout though yeah
thank you for the record uh marty carlin
representing
uh you nhrs a handout from the
retirement system that sort of
summarizes the
the change as well as the uh the number
of people affected by that and also
explains how the that middle tier works
in terms of minimum age and minimum
service for retirement so that
their
people who choose to elect to do this
would be buying back up to get them to
uh you know the old 45 and 20 or in some
increment closer to it you know if they
only want to buy one year instead of if
they were eligible for more
the reason that bill has an fn is the
original
version uh introduced in the senate um
had a calculation uh like a like a
set in set in stone
calculation for the service purchase
that the actuary thought didn't capture
the full cost so it had about a 12
million dollar price tag on the original
bill the senate amended it so that it's
all on the member who chooses to buy it
okay anybody have any questions for mr
carlin
yes representative griffin uh mr chair i
will uh make a motion
that we
accept uh senate bill
363 is ought to pass
okay motion to ought to pass on 363 do
we have a second second
okay
motion made in second any other further
discussion
okay seeing then we'll
call the roll
okay
uh mr chairman yes
vice chairman yes the clerk votes yes
representative booney yes representative
hatch yes representative walsh yes
representative schultz yes seven or
nothing
mr chairman the motion about the past
passes
okay so we were report to full finance
for tomorrow uh 363 otp
yeah really i thought you would have
otherwise you know like sometimes i'm
here after a while
yes
if
okay
okay marty could you spell your last
name
that's why i asked i remember from
previous testimonies i'm going is it a k
or c
okay okay
thanks
bye
okay being to 2 30 we'll start the work
is there anyone here would like to
thank you mr chair carol mcguire
merrimack district 29
and senate bill 443 is the result of a
study committee last year on how we
adopt updates to the building code
the actual update was included in house
bill 1681 which the senate has passed so
we don't have to worry about that this
deals with some other
issues that have become noticeable
the first part is that
municipalities have the authority to
adopt
amendments to the state building code
in some cases the amendments have
been
incorrect
or in conflict with the building code
not always usually there they're fine
and you also end up with really bizarre
cases where
i think it's pelham and hudson where one
town picks option a for how you do you
contain electrical cables the other one
has option b
and so on you've got to switch over from
there they're both legitimate but having
them next to each other is a problem and
many people who work across the state
from contractors
to electricians to building inspectors
don't have a good way to find these
amendments
some of them are on
municipalities website some of them
aren't so this would require the
building code review board to actually
look at these amendments
confirm that they are not in conflict
with the state building code
and publish them so that every everybody
can look up and say okay i'm going to do
put up a building in
in dover
and this is the building code this is
these are the amendments i have to
follow
and so that's much easier for everybody
so this describes the process where that
happens
the fire code is also in the same
situation so this
adds that
local amendments to the fire code are to
be reviewed by the
state fire marshal and
because the board of fire control only
meets monthly
and they don't or maybe it's less than
that they don't meet very often and they
wouldn't be able to to work on it
properly
but the fire
there are fewer amendments to the fire
so this requires some act some
administrative
processes and
the boards do not have the authority to
deny
a valid building code
amendment this of the locality they can
simply they can tell you
it it conflicts with the state building
code and therefore you can't adopt it
but if it's in accordance with the state
building code or fire code they can only
say
it's a legitimate change
they might add under their breath but we
think you're an idiot for doing it but
that's but you can still do it
and you know
that's yes but the towns have the
authority to adopt any
uh compatible amendment that they choose
and which is
why we left it that's it
and the cost is simply for some clerical
help the fire marshal and the state
board of fire control and the state
building
building code review board have been
struggling for years with inadequate
express the need for more personnel
the effect is as you got the revised
fiscal mode it doesn't
this isn't effective until january so
you're only talking a short period
before the next budget
um
i will try to answer questions if you
have any
okay just so you have uh mr hoffman
passed out a supplemental fiscal
statement that reflects the half here
questions
yes representative burris yeah thank you
thank you uh mr chairman just a
question out of curiosity can a town
pass a more stringent code
they can only pass a more stringent code
okay thank you
unless they fire unless the code has
options in which case they can pick any
of them they like but in general their
their amendments must be
congruent with or stricter than the
represented walls
um so i know representative mcwilliams
mothers have tried to
pass updates to the building code and
the fire code and my question is
was that if they did that
what it had do you know if it would have
standardized the codes here's my concern
is it sounds like we have
almost a different code in every town
and is there a way that we can
standardize it throughout the state and
is that what they were trying to do in
the past
i
have no idea what they were trying to do
in the past
this year this year we adopted the 2018
building codes
and
statewide
and that's that is in house bill 1681
and and and any town that has an
amendment to the building code will
probably need to look at
if it's still necessary regarding the
update to the code
the
there were a lot of changes and issues
because
we kept the 2009 building code through
yeah yeah now we we we're on
we're slightly behind because we found
that if you
the state that the building codes
have some some issues when they first
come out so we want to be
at least two years after the code's
adopted
so there the building code review board
is thinking about when they should start
looking at the 2021 codes
other questions and this is the
international building code is that the
who is it the international building
code or just the national
yeah
most of them are international right um
it's
it's not in this bill it's it's
specified in house bill 1681 right that
was just a curiosity question i think
they're international yeah
other questions
thank you
anyone else like to speak on this
representative
griffin i opened my cutting even sure i
think are we ready for a motion i think
we have some uh there's probably some
anybody else like to make a comment
until we run out of time then we're not
eaters at all
good afternoon brian allen from the fire
marshal's office uh the fire marshal is
could you spell you laugh sure uh
a-l-l-a-r-d first name brian
uh the fire marshal couldn't be there
here this week he's away on vacation
uh we just want to speak to the
the fiscal note uh as
as was brought up just uh prior to me
speaking is you know we do have this
would be an extra demand on our staff uh
which is already uh at capacity now so
we just want to stress that if there's
any questions i could answer with
regards to
the fiscal note i'm happy to do
that you have any questions
okay well thank you
thank you uh
my name is gary abbott i'm the executive
vice president of the associated general
contractors of new hampshire
i've been supportive of this bill all
the way through the process
in support of the department and
personnel to do this
you're right it's the international
billing codes which is the the main
codes for commercial residential
and those associated codes
there are different codes for like the
fire codes and those kind of things so
that's why under 1681 you'll find all
the different codes
clearly this is a great thing from the
construction aspect if we can find all
the amendments in one location
through the state building code review
board and file that the department of
safety the other issue is is i have a
representative on the building code
review board
and they are already looking at the 2021
international building codes
so it's going through the review process
very optimistic that now that we're
getting back on track and keeping up
we won't have the problems that were
discussed a little earlier regarding
being behind
in towns trying to do an effort to catch
up if the state is catching up there
won't be any reason for the
municipalities to put in a lot of
amendments so that's the hope
and with that i would hope the committee
supports the bill okay any questions
thank
please
my name is phillip sherman i'm the chair
of the building code review board
this bill reflects many hours working
with eight representative groups and
many individuals to correct a
long-standing problem in new hampshire
a building on what representative
mcguire said currently there's
jurisdictions where regulations are
adopted without going through the
ordinance process as required by rsa 674
and statutory requirements that
ordinances be forwarded to the bcrb
basically for posting on the website
have been satisfied by a grand total of
two jurisdictions i think portsmouth and
durham
further some local ordinances do not
even reflect the current state codes
there's a fairly significant city not
too far from here that still posted the
2009 codes this bill therefore reflects
a desire for some level of bcrb review
of local amendments to the building and
also the fire codes the bcrb consists of
17 volunteer members
with administrative support from the
state fire marshal's office
while many of the 234 towns and cities
do not have code amendments you can't
you can't have a code amendment unless
you have the whole building inspector
package
dealing with the ones that do will
require support by staff having an
understanding of the technical aspects
of the code in other words in excess of
the clerical support that we currently
receive
so speaking on the building code side we
support this strongly and i think
there's a very real problem out there
and this is the way to fix it
how
um
i have a couple architects that live
within my constituency and uh
one of them a couple times has come
where he's having problems with
communities
outside my area that
this
exact problem exists their current
building codes
are not current
the ones that the municipality
municipalities using what resource does
he have to
address that other than going to the
state he's had he's frustrated um and i
don't know if you've experienced this
before but
i i suspect and this is just a personal
opinion that much of that problem
our jurisdictions that are enforcing the
state building go their websites are
just out of date
like everybody those things tend to get
stale and forgotten about
uh i'm there may be towns that are
literally enforcing out-of-date codes in
which case they need a phone call to
just bring them up to speed
uh this gets more to the local amendment
problem
where as others have have indicated
frequently the building or the fire
official will just say this is what i
want and whereas the rsa requires those
amendments to go through the local
ordinance process
and then in terms of the need for a
central repository so that you know a
person can figure out what's going on
it's just not being complied with even
for informational purposes
for the most part
thanks
it's not precisely
what i had i'm happy to give this to you
it would just go in the folder if
yes
good afternoon thank you steve levoy i'm
the director of administration for the
named sure lavoy lav as in victor o-i-e
yep
um and just as assistant director allard
mentioned you know the department is
fully in support of of the bill i just
wanted to make sure the committee was
aware the fiscal note that's attached is
not funded and the position is not
authorized in the current language
so if we were to receive that position
there would need to be an amendment made
so as of now there is no administrative
support for this function within
the division of fire safety in the fire
marshal's office
i'm happy to take any questions
[Music]
because what we're voting on is a
position
and you're you're saying that position
doesn't exist or so that takes a
different an additional
amendment
so the language in the bill
right right now does not speak to that
position
the fiscal note brought it forward as a
concern
that the department had about meeting
the requirements of the bill so this
fiscal note is
would be nice to have
not what is we we would say it's a
well i'm a little confused but right now
in finance before us it says here's what
we might spend over the next couple of
years
and that's what we're voting on
and if the position doesn't exist
mr hoffman do you have a
thought
the bill does not establish a position
or make an appropriation
department of safety submitted the
fiscal information
that says
if we're going to do this we need this
position it's going to cost us that
so
if it were passed
approval and actuality okay because i
was sitting there thinking all of a
sudden we got to report this out three
o'clock tomorrow afternoon and you want
us to create a position
i don't know if that's going to happen
but uh
if we approve the appropriation then at
least
well what are we
just identifying
oh okay so we're not voting anything the
if if we vote this ought to pass what
have we decided
with the policy this is a policy the
part of the budget for a
position that we've made
you're right ask a dutchman he'll do
something yeah
okay i understand now
we're voting on a policy in finance i
always
get a kick out of it okay any other
question sir mr lavoie
right
any other questions from mr lavoy thank
yes yes it is
throw me down the stairs my hat i know
yes
oh
so the good intentions were there to
uh
i move uh senate bill
443 as octopass
second okay motion made and seconded any
other further discussion
okay if the clerk would call the roll
all right the chairman votes yes vice
chairman
yes
yes representative
yes represent hatch yes
okay so we're posted to full finance
tomorrow at three o'clock has ought to
pass
and so that ends the work session on
four four three
i'll open the work session on senate
bill 438
and ask anybody that would like to
contribute wisdom and knowledge to us
you have to turn the mic on
there you go and if you introduce
yourselves for the clerk and he's
probably going to ask you how to spell
good afternoon uh house finance
committee members my name is steven
capone that's c-a-p-o-n-e i'm president
of capone corporation north woods and
the steel fabricators of new england i'm
here with holly novoleski of novel iron
and stephen chasey of s.l chasey steele
three family
generational family businesses
um
my testimony will be with respect to
opposing arguments that we may have
heard
uh over the past few months as we've
tried to promote our bill
i just want to take an opportunity
some of your time to discuss some of
these arguments i'll try to stay
respectful of your time of course and um
focus really on the fiscal
one of the um one of the arguments we
heard was um basically about economic
ignorance
actually this this bill is is really to
correct that and come back with
responsible economics uh simply put
keeping tax dollars in our new hampshire
communities
is keeping local people employed you
know they in turn spend within their own
communities and it's called the economic
multiplier
in economic multipliers for every dollar
spent
in our communities a dollar fifty is
generated right here in our local
communities i believe holly novoletsky
is gonna expand upon that
um
if these dollars leave our country
though
zero is generated in our community and
there's nothing ignorant about that
another argument that we heard was it
will impede economic growth
to the contrary it will foster economic
growth
um and really uh if that will speak for
itself you know um
conversely you know we're funding the
growth of canadian businesses and
economies at our own expense with these
tax dollars that we pay on these public
construction projects
another argument is
money versus wealth
money flowing out of the country might
be a good thing
i say might be good
any tax dollar flowing out of our
country at any rate is never a good
thing there is no economic multiplier
benefit from it
another argument is
this bill will raise costs
no it won't this is a short-sighted
response
negligible
initial savings on publicly funded
construction projects
will disappear
you will not get an economic multiply in
fact in the long run saving a little
upfront obviously will cost us more
later on
our economic activity will far exceed
any discount of the purchase of fabric
another argument is the seen versus
unforeseen effect prices will rise and
taxes will increase no
projects will be competitively
competitively priced and new hampshire
will not need to increase taxes because
of this legislation
it's more likely that new hampshire will
see an increase in tax revenues
generated by this economic activity
another argument
cited unprecedented delays on projects
due to strained supply chains
again no
it will help rebuild and strengthen our
supply chains we learned from the
one would say this bill is subsidizing
an industry
there's nothing in our bill that
requires uh or requests a subsidy or tax
break um
on on you know on our behalf
um
this bill is only protecting four
fabricators
again no there were four of us
championing this bill however we
represent over 22 other steel
fabricators in the state of new
hampshire minimum 22 i should say and
over 900 employees
the economic multiplier ripples through
the industry and will have a positive
economic impact on the residents of new
hampshire
i like this one
we should thank canada for their low
prices
you can thank them for using our own tax
dollars to support canadian communities
yes you can thank canadi that you can
thank them when canadian steel
fabricators put us out of business using
canada does subsidize its industries and
at a power at a minimum with power
electric electricity and natural gas and
health insurance
this alone won't solve our problem here
but at least it'll give us a fighting
chance
capone irons own health insurance
premium increased 24 percent this year
we're paying close to one million
dollars this year for our health
insurance
so
ace you know any sort of um
argument against health insurance
or power or anything like that would be
negligible but it would help us it would
i'll leave you with these last few
thoughts
this bill is focused on the responsible
spending of our tax dollars on
structural steel fabrication products
keeping our tax dollars in our state
will yield positive results in our local
and regional communities
outside of a one-time potential upfront
discount
realized by buying fabricated steel from
north of the border there is no economic
gain to our communities once that money
is spent
competitive pricing practices project
schedules material availability quality
and capacity will not be compromised as
this bill has waivers to protect both
public and pr the public and project's
interests
again a short term expense
for a long-term gain
when our tax revenue expenditures
replenish our economies and communities
not communities in another country this
positive cycle will just keep going
employees will keep working spending
their money in our communities and will
continue to stabilize our economy
i thank you for your time could we get a
copy of your testimony i haven't sure
i failed to mention that i have
many letters of support from local
thank you
if you have any questions please
any questions
good afternoon i'm holly novletsky i am
the owner and uh ceo of novel ironworks
in greenland new hampshire last name is
v e
l e
thank you for this opportunity to speak
buy american is a bipartisan value
senate bill 438 is a buy american bill
it will support and protect american
jobs american manufacturing
and the american economy
senate bill 438 is about good
if you look at it as short-term versus
long-term investment short-term
investment would be if you buy the
cheaper steel
from a foreign company
but that money goes out of them out of
the country and is not reinvested
long-term investment strategy pays
dividends to our local economy it
preserves and creates better paying jobs
in new hampshire
it has a multiplying effect in the local
community
supporting local businesses and it
increases the state's tax revenue
by
by foregoing the immediate gratification
of cheaper upfront price for steel the
long-term reinvestment in our
manufacturing base and middle class will
strengthen the economy encourage
repatriating
repatriating that's a tongue twister
manufacturing
and grow our middle class
i submitted last night my testimony so
you have all of it but i would like to
offer i have an example
from real life that i can go through
with you on a job that was a new
hampshire-based job
that went canadian that we lost i can go
through that with you or
if you'd like
okay
so recently we bid a job
in new hampshire it was the nashua
middle school we bid it last year for
delivery this summer
we came in third the first two were four
and they were canadian
our price was five hundred thousand
dollars
more than the neck than the winning bid
our price was 6.9 million
if you think about uh the difference
between 6.9 and 6.4 which was the
winning bid it was 7.5 price
differentiation
steel tends to be 10
of the overall project cost so for
0.75 percent we lost the bid of an
increase to the project
but what was lost was more to the state
and when you include employee wages that
were gone towards building that school
which were 20 and this is just sharp
this is not my office
this is just the shop wages
we lost
250 000 in wages shop wages for that job
with an average federal tax of 15
percent
lost one thousand dollars
the new hampshire bet one thousand two
hundred sixty dollars
the new hampshire
bt
bpt i'm dyslexic sorry um on that
contract the profit 10 on a 6.9 million
dollar project was 53 million dollars
and the new hampshire unemployment one
percent was 2500 for a total of 337 990
just on the shop costs
that the state lost
when you look at the multiplier effect
that stephen was talking about
so for every one dollar of can paid
for construction a dollar fifty is
recirculated through respending into the
economy
if you look at the price
our bid price was 6.9 million the
canadians were
6.4 we backed out the erection because
both of us would have used domestic
erection so we took that price out to be
conservative
and you apply the 1.5 percent 1.5 um
multiplier effect
what the state lost
was eight million four hundred and sixty
one thousand dollars and five hundred
dollars in reinvesting through the
multiplier effect in the local community
if you
want to be even more conservative and
take the five hundred thousand dollars
that they saved up front you're still
looking at almost eight million dollars
that the state lost and reinvesting in
local community
senate bill 438 creates jobs
strengthens our
local economy our supply chains in our
middle class it does not ask for a
subsidy
or a tax break
it only
will generate more tax by more domestic
spending
and more domestic jobs
any questions
questions
yes
yes thank you mr trump thank you holly
for being here i can't pronounce your
last name i apologize i mean out of
curiosity when the canadians bid on
something is it in canadian dollars or
us dollars
u.s u.s okay
is that u.s u.s thank you
but with the exchange rate ranging
anywhere from 1.25 to 1.30
something
right there's a
any other other
questions thank you thank you for your
senator i didn't see you sitting over
there sorry about that
uh for the record
my name is senator tom sherman i'm the
prime sponsor of the bill
um
and um i represent district 24
this
is a
nonpartisan or bipartisan bill that
recognizes that in new hampshire we have
four major steel fabricating plants
one of these is in my district and holly
is
the ceo and owner of that
i had a tour of this complex following a
discussion with holly
the companies are responsible employers
with dedicated employees
but they're competing with foreign
manufacturers for work in new hampshire
and across new england
i learned that the playing field is
anything but level
with many of these foreign producers due
to government support favorable tax
structures and or exchange rates able to
offer their products
at such low prices that our own in-state
manufacturers can't compete
our granite state fabricators have
compelling stories which they have
shared with you of being unable to bid
for contracts even in the cities and
municipalities in which their factories
are located
the concept behind the bill is not new
it is standard of practice for federal
highway projects
in fact over on the senate side we had
d.o.t come and help us with the
amendment that you see before you
recently there's been a movement in
state legislators legislatures across
the country to level the playing field
to support american-made products by
ensuring that they are utilized in these
publicly funded projects
no impact on private projects
one critical lesson we've learned during
covid is the price of outsourcing
manufacturing beyond our u.s borders
whether it's ppe plexiglas ventilators
or other products essential to
protecting the health of americans
during the pandemic the lack of
availability within the united states
created significant barriers
to access during the crisis
and persistent broad foreign supply
chain shortages
continue to drive up consumer prices at
home
supporting us-based manufacturing as
anticipated in this bill especially new
hampshire-based manufacturing ensures
that there will be high quality
production
on american soil supports local job
growth with excellent wages and benefits
and represents a direct investment in
our own businesses and economy
while some may claim this may drive up
choi uh costs at least 21 states have
laws that require government preference
for american-made materials and products
38 states have in-state procurement
preference for manufacturers
and
as holly said there is a return on
investment that's
pretty remarkable at uh one and a half
dollars for every dollar spent
similar legislation passed recently in
new jersey and did so unanimously in
texas
it is now under consideration in
massachusetts interestingly countries
that represent current foreign sources
of similar products
often allow their regional governments
and provinces to pass the exact same
type of guard rails
contemplated in this bill to support
their own local industries in other
words we can't compete
in the countries that are
competing with us here at home
this is not simply a matter of new
hampshire jobs and businesses it has
grown to be an issue of national
economic security
in the senate after introducing sb 438
and hearing the testimony from
contractors and the municipal
association as well as others
we all sat down together with senator
carson
and amended the bill to what you have
before you today all stakeholders have
signed off on the bill
we refined the definition to be very
specific we put in place metrics for the
implementation as well as a waiver
process and we made sure that compliance
and accountability also had some teeth
using standard language from the
department of revenue administration for
similar processes
uh it was further amended as you're
probably aware by
by the house in a way that
made it even better
while allowing for appropriate
exemptions the bill
requires the state to reinvest taxpayer
dollars in our own local regional and
statewide economies
i hope you'll support the bill and thank
you i'm happy to take any questions
have any questions
yes
representative schultz hi senator hi
um
just a quick question i love uh this
concept of this bill
and uh giving the
preferential option on american
materials was there ever any thought of
also including american unionized labor
um
right now it actually this is
supported
in every state including texas where
it's been introduced by the unions
because
again
this is not just about
using steel
in american jobs american steel and
american jobs but the steel that the
fabricators use is from america as well
so many of the jobs that it's supporting
is supporting union labor so it's not a
union bill per se but the unions
were part of the group that actually
brought it to my attention so they are
other questions
senator can we get a copy of your
testimony to share the file thank you
yeah i can give you this one
i would just like to make a comment we
used to have and roberts aware of them
isaac's instructor steele which is the
same industries that sees
that closed for different reasons and i
won't go into the reasons but
after that close the dealership
dropped 21 vehicles per year
that used to go to isaacson structured
steel and were never gained back whether
the employees were dispersed throughout
the state but that's just one little
tidbit
of economic loss
um with that one closure of a place that
i suspect is very similar
to what we're talking about here so
this is real stuff
and unfortunately where i live we can
speak to a lot of things like this but
nevertheless i just would like to bring
that out thank you thank you
thank you thank you
anyone else like to
thank you mr chairman thank you members
of
house finance i was involved in the
house amendment that removed the 25
threshold that was originally in the
bill
i want to tackle a couple of things
the reason that the house did
edna remove that is because there was
a a
range if you will to have criteria there
was concern that that would just cause
the
bidders to have an open window to
inflate
i don't necessarily agree with that but
we took it out
so it doesn't exist
one of the things that i want to talk
about in reference to this in my
concerns references back to some of the
things we've seen in the last four years
some of the things the former
president's been concerned of and that
is critical type of
manufacturing that the united states
used to lead the world in
has is either dried up it's drying up or
it's frankly being shipped overseas
the bentley chevrolet in my district
has 15 new cars
period
in this dealership because they rely
on a product that came from overseas and
we've seen
what that ultimately is doing not only
to to the supply chain of certain things
but the generalized economy in the
united states
we've we've lost two steel fabricators
in new hampshire already
we have a handful left
i don't want to see another industry
that is critical to the operations of
this state go away
one of the things that i'm concerned
about based on some of the two speeches
that were given
on the floor of the house
that were grossly incorrect one of them
involved restricting this bill
in a way that only four people can bid
on that that's that is totally not true
it's not in the bill
the steel fabricators will still have to
bid for the jobs it is not restricted to
new hampshire only so you're going to
have competitors in massachusetts in
maine and the regional area will still
have the right to bid
and the safeguards that are involved
don't require that the state procurement
attend to any of them i sit on the state
procurement commission right now the
chairman of the state procurement
commission senator carson is a
co-sponsor of this bill
i've looked this over from the
in those eyes if you will my procurement
glasses
and there's enough
carve outs in this that it doesn't bind
the state to anything
if
the folks in the room the folks out
there that do this type of work if they
come in with bids that the state feels
are are
not in line with say some of the foreign
entities the state has the right to
reject them and cost is a is a listed
factor
so this does not lock the state of new
hampshire into
a limited window of a limited group
that's bidding
in a situation where they all know each
other that doesn't exist here
so this still retains a competitive
marketplace
and it still allows the state and out
overall
personally i think
that
we have gone on too long
relying on foreign markets for
everything
and
that needs to cease we have got to
retain
what this what the united states
is really was really known for in the
world
and steel is definitely one of those
things
we also heard testimony or at least a
speech on the floor of the house
concerning supply chains and i had to
laugh when they
when the speaker referenced the fact
that a supply chain from china
in essence would be
better than a supply chain internally
that's insane
we've seen huge problems with overseas
shipping and huge problems with people
getting stuff to coming in from from the
asian markets
i don't know where he he got came up
with that idea but domestic steel is
here
i don't need to worry about a ship
sitting off the port of long beach
right so
this is a matter of allowing the these
folks to
to basically get into a level playing
field now i've had the fortune and i
won't i won't mention the company but
i've had the fortune of touring one of
these facilities recently to get an idea
and all i saw was hard work and fellas
in
by the way a non-union shop so this this
is not about unions at all it's got
nothing to do with unions frankly this
is just about
new hampshire jobs new hampshire
businesses new hampshire economy getting
their fair
look at
and that's what it's about that's why
that's why i'm in favor of it that's why
i spoke out on the floor of the house
and i'll continue to support it
and i just asked the finance committee
to think about this as you would in
financial terms if the state of new
hampshire is not locked into this and
cost can be a factor for rejection
questions
yes represented
i have a question and it may be a better
question for one of the fabricators but
while the
tariffs were in effect on canadian steel
did that affect what was going on with
the contracts here and did it affect the
market here in the states i can't speak
to that but i'll tell you this when the
federal government puts a tariff in they
do it for a reason right because
they recognize there's a there's an
unfair advantage that's what a tariff
does
as i said on the floor of the house when
they literally can drill a hole
in steel and then say well it's
processed it's it's literally a loophole
all jokes aside they literally just
drill a damn hole in the steel
so
clearly
the foreign markets are going to do
everything they can to try to get around
the tariffs that the united states has
put on
foreign steel so does that affect their
world i i can guarantee it to what
extent they could tell you better than i
could
please
i can see you
so i believe you're talking about the
tariffs 232 that went in about raw
material
and that wasn't against uh canada canada
as actually doesn't have any steel mills
they have to buy their raw material
outside
they either buy it from us they buy it
from china they can buy it from
europe
so
they were able to as as representative
pearson was saying they buy foreign
steel themselves they fabricate it
it
it circumvents terrace because the
i was just sitting here googling and
under our former president there were
tariffs that went in against canadian
steel and aluminum it was a joint tariff
that went in
that made me think it might have
affected your industry and raw material
so they do produce um tube but not
structural steel thank you
it's difficult to follow a rock star
like that when it comes to the steel
fabrication industry in new hampshire so
i'm just gonna end what uh
my point here but that that's that's my
concern with finance is that you guys
just look at the the financial
implications and risks as i did as a
member of the state procurement
commission and just see
hopefully what what i see so thank you
it's curious to me that this is another
bill that has no money in it
and here we are in finance
charged with
financial responsibility but there isn't
any
what's the pleasure of the committee
uh mr chair i will move uh senate bill
438 fm uh ought to pass okay
motion made by representative griffin
seconded by representative hatch any
further comment
okay the clerk will call the roll
okay the motion is on senate bill 438 is
ought to pass if you're in favor you'll
go to the affirmative if not you'll vote
in the negative
i'll start with the chairman yes
vice chairman yes the clerk votes yes
representative mooney yes representative
hatch yes representative walls yes
representative schultz yes
mr chairman the motion passed seven to
nothing
438 will be recommended to fill finance
tomorrow executive session three o'clock
yes
but i still would like it all come
together it doesn't matter
you